welcome all and good morning my name is
Chris Roy I'm the consultant basically
from Victoria and I manage that Gerry
says grain storage extension project
this morning's topic as you can see on
your screen is best results for bags and
blankets some quick housekeeping before
we get going there's a Q&A window the
choker you can define which allows you
to ask your question click the Q&A
window to open up pop your question and
then if you'd like to send a question
anonymously just tick where it says
senators please feel free to ask
questions as we go out I can kick this
presentation interactive and answer your
questions I've also like to thank the
virtual copy work for facilitating
session for today if you are having any
trouble hearing me or or connecting
those contacting they pay me oh this
results for bunker storage bags where do
they fit into this system often here
they will just come to me and they say
old creme bags they're cheap right but
they any good for me yes they do have a
place in the system yes they have a
lower capital cost they tend to have a
bit higher maintenance and a bit higher
labor requirement they expect the
obvious and and they to make them really
they're really well suited to the
shorter term storage so if you think
about the higher volume lower very sort
of commodities ideal for those things
like how is the distance and ideally you
really limit them to dry grain moisture
driving bags because we don't have a way
there efficiently with bags it's really
about from the experience I see around
the place in
tell me about it's really about the
effort your team if you don't put much
effort in don't expect a great result if
you put the effort in then you can make
them work very well and you can expect
to stall them for a bit longer obviously
if you imagine a graph of time and risk
longer the bag is down the higher the
risk becomes of something going wrong
that bag the gravy Burma getting in
there pests getting in there grain
quality loss so ideally in short term
however statistics if there's a really
good spot for them nineteen years we've
got a bit high volume of grain that
you've got to hold but not the
anticipating to hold it for too long
site selection preparation
moving is key you see occasionally the
the bag one bag in the corner of a cap a
and unfortunately there we have a
typical scenarios where I see if they
will have how the issues one because
it's not the best site and it's not
managed that well though site selection
really is important so ideally we have a
central site written a few central sites
around the farm that allow us to have
all-weather access to that site and some
way that we're going to be driving past
regularly so at least weekly we need to
be checking the bags and packing in
holes dealing with any grammar issues
things like that so a central site with
several central sites around the farm
where all your bags are stored in the
same way you can set up your silo you
put them all at a central spot so that
they're much easier to monitor manage
and therefore you're more likely to do
it oh this one's higher ground I dealing
with a slight slope and you can see the
picture here we'll go bag which is on a
bit of a rise which is great
anything I do if I was doing the bagging
would be to start at the top of the
slide and run the bag again just with
water drain
make sure it runs down the hill away
from the bag and the pinion walks it
seal mechanism e-news at the end of the
bag probably better than the other way
obviously if you put it across a slope
the war is going to run down the
intended compacted service I've got
written there put a nice cratered
surface in this picture well I have seen
plenty of times is when the rain comes
and falls on the bag runs around the
side beside the bag a little bit we
don't cover slow and that'll soften the
ground underneath the bag and then they
later the bet black-saw make it sink
into the soil and so what you end up
with a bag it might be a little way
under the compaction suits into the
ground and so if there is a hole under
there if my sleeve even underneath them
into a hole with the grain bag sitting
active surface so the bags it's nice and
firm on top of the green and really also
I stopped more poorly beside obvious pre
of sticks and sharp rocks they told me
to take them all away from Queens where
birds nests
obviously birds are they have an issue
with banks so having a site that's away
from the bird's nest another obvious one
but something that I hadn't thought
about if someone told me another one the
creditor to the paper would do a bag
they've passed on a lot of their tips
and tricks of working what hasn't
but away from sand hills on the long
grass where rabbits and foxes tenderly
obviously rabbits not a huge issue
prepared but what chases the rabbit
these problems and Fox is running over
top of the bag taking them away from
those samples and long grass
first if I suppose is to select the
quality bag and that can be one of the
first helpful tip someone Gavin was
absolutely super Thums it in the photo
here I've got a demonstration what I
mean by thumb just giving it a sampler
bag or corner bag and just kind of stick
that thumb through it to to see how hard
or how easy it is to actually punch it
about the head improved since they first
come to Australia the quality of bag
casino is much better than it started
out to be something to just be aware of
I don't set much and more people selling
silage bag of grain bags and they just
not this not that a bag with a stretch
mark on it also makes life easier come
with a rule or so you just measure up
here speech that the manufacturer
recommends things like that to make it
easier when you try to give it back I
don't have been research on this but in
have said they sprinkle a little bit of
your ear on the ground before laying bag
good to the mice and Kenny research
around how that works or what it works
but anecdotally ceiling the starting end
of a bag is quite important you might
have seen or in my review real easy
method of punching the bag up putting
tabble trial in and stop being
underneath itself it really is not the
best option for a few reasons one of the
main ones is when you come to into the
bag the square of the starting wing
there where shopping you have to do
really shuffling so whatever we can do
to make that Joe lead you the better so
starting with a nice square in where
they use this here together at seal or a
couple of bits of timber clamp together
and then roll it under each other roll
it under it so
[Music]
seal and a square obviously when you're
feeling they want to get the correct
stretch don't overfill the bag there
where if you haven't used bags before
that they will stretch out a lot more
when it's warmer itself stretcher bar
easier doing a bag on cool day versus
filling the bag on a hot day will be
will be a little bit different so I've
got straight this some people might
think that's a little bit picky little
bit finicky that we need the bag
straight couple reasons for that though
one is that it's a lot easier when it
comes to out loading if you've got a
straight bag to follow this one the
other one is in the front you have got a
couple of creases forming in the bag
every time the bag changes direction
until called a crease and those creases
we find a wear mask and most likely to
attack because I can chew the bag so the
straighter we get it for those creases
their spots we've got to the mass to
access and down here like I said before
well look at this photo you can see the
site here it's always suggesting the
core of paddock again not more not not
my preference I understand that's very
convenient for harvest logistics to run
out straight from the chase then into a
bag in the toilet paddy it's not ideal
and and really limits the time that I
would be comfortable waiting bag leave
the grain stored in the bag so if it's
just half of logistics for a month and
we want to take the risk on be another
half loaded when it's dry and not too
wet do start in crazy
after filling obviously we've got to
seal up the the end of the bag well if
we're finished if you know go to a bit
of effort here you can get proper heat
seals just to seal that up properly to
keep the moisture out it seems like a
pretty simple thing but what people tell
me that the moisture moisture will find
its way in there if it's not done
properly so if you really have got worth
going effort again clamp the tube it's a
timber together our father saw the bag
roll it under itself and then put some
dirt on top of it
hold that end in that opening listen to
it obviously you've got to leave some
bag access there if the unloader started
so some dirt on the top will stop that
back in the end and seal that then fence
off the side of course even if we don't
have sheep on our farm there's always a
story of the neighbors sheep got out and
run over the top of my bag or some well
go to something or wild pigs building it
and made a mess so I would recommend
defense inside the gals of whether
you've got livestock or not there's
always something that we do Petare
fighting a mice you can do a pretty
simple bait station to bait the mice and
clean up any spills happened around the
site you can send the left hand side
here we've got a beautiful hard
compacted site here that makes it really
easy to clean up grains pills
and the reason for that is to to remove
a reason for both grain pests and vermin
lice birds
anything like that to be actually
attracted to the bag to be attracted to
the site so if we clean those fills up
and remove me from the site completely
we remove the temptation in the
attraction same as when we're patching
the bag we're going there monitoring
patching them that's about stopping
their attraction stopping them spilling
growing out and stopping the photo on
the right here we've got a nice simple
fence around it to stop of them and
don't like though is that left the grass
grower in the bag which again is a
shelter there for the mice or insects
not ideal and you can set it up right
beside a built in fresh tree line which
might be convenient in the court of a
paddock but that's it's just providing
food for those birds needs to control
witches regular monitoring I've already
touched on we here weekly is the ideal
for patching bags again depending on
where they are and how much pressure
they are under wrong vermin I've had a
couple people tell me they have got to
go around them every couple of days to
patch them again as soon as you've got a
hole you've got a spot for grinding it
out that becomes an attraction for more
of them and that also is a spot where
moisture can get in so soon you've got a
moisture coming into a bag you're much
more likely to have brain damage of
course but also provides a really nice
spot for insects to start bringing moist
grain got a sample the bag check for
moisture temperature insect pests have
antennae soon it and a great system for
the sampling but I'm sure you guys have
got them whether you use a speed and
take around the speed so that it doesn't
tear the bag Mars the grain but same way
we market lining up any other silos
leaving the market cleaning bags as well
obviously if we have big Brian full
events you want to dry in the board away
you know put this picture in to
demonstrate they've got a bag nice and
straight which is making unloading easy
and see it's not too many holes it's
likely not put the bag down for too long
so well it's in a paddock and right
beside some trees
they're doing the right thing not baby
bear too long expected me to be either
stored or brain here quick frozen frozen
cons of bags certain low capital cost
upfront they do allow that segregation
flexible capacity flexible in location
meet leasing ground or you've got a farm
that's the distance from the home place
and it's not convenient to cart going
home you could set up a bag use like
they're so flexible location the conned
things to be aware of they will require
a bit more labor so it takes two people
to load the bag and ideally color people
to fill them successfully you could
probably take shortcut but again every
shortcut you take really reduces how
good a job you're going to do and
therefore how long you can store the
plane successfully in the bag the pilot
we we don't novel successful way to be
irate the grinding bags Lee in there so
cooling I wish to there's some risk with
with damage and loss with a bag all
things I'm telling you here is to try a
minimum or inspectors and the limited
storage look people tell me about stored
in bags really comfortably for up to 12
months but the other people that have
done everything absolutely ideal is like
me if you're going to take shortcuts or
perhaps it's it's not an ideal situation
then really talking about storage really
quick summary on bags there let's have a
quick look of bankers while we're going
on temporary storage very similar to
bags in the site selection we want
somewhere high we want good drainage to
keep the moisture away they compacted
pad again for the same reasons as we
could do with bags we don't want the
weight of the grain forcing a little
depression in the soil and then creating
spot
a graded slope so if you imagine a
roadway black should want a graded canva
across the pub area and then we want to
actually slow down so the water runs out
of that bunker area as well so the
camber and it's like it really is worth
building and building website for a
bunker if they will say part of their
site selection for a bunker if they've
got really flat ground is actually where
they've got access to some filth and
bunker walls look doesn't always be you
don't have to have a wall around the
bunker
so the increases your capacity and it
can help with sealing the top down a bit
better and holding top having something
to command it to you concrete ballz
obviously ideal is it the clamping
system but what I wouldn't recommend is
using hay or straw as a wall purely
because insects blowing pests in Bangka
capacity to a few ways to go about it I
put this table in here the people
interested they can jump on on the
website afterwards and look it up from
the store crank ombré your website or or
of course this just wouldn't have a you
know idea start with how high your all
there is Gannett going to stack the
grain so if you've got an order that can
reach up four meters expect your hub of
that this is in wheat and it's expected
the battle to get 700 meters wide given
the angle of repose for weight if you
adjusted a cone if you're looking about
225 ton capacity as the example if you
went 30 meters long
if you fitting weight
it said number 60 cubic meters but
really any loot I will break to figure
out the capacity of a bunker the other
way to do it of course is to calculate
it for yourself the angle of repose for
the various grains here a growing coffee
it was a calculation here which you can
do and then obviously your volume
manners and then you convert that to the
conversion factors where they're storing
weight or value give you an idea of
having a pad you need to grade half a
part you need to put your bunker walls
bunker operation I would always
recommend the bottom top I have heard
people say that they use the top top for
a few years and then that becomes a
bottom top you can do that with no
separate but a lot of quality top for
the bottom the top top there are quite
significant differences in the quality
of top that you can get so again if you
let me at the bunker for more than
short-term storage the quality
difference and having a way to seal it
down this is an ideal method to be able
to clamp the top down to that concrete
bunker wall obviously if we're going to
do a bank on either a method for
removing the top depending on the
conditions if there's a bit of breeze it
can be quite dangerous and seriously
injured trying to remove taps will put
taps on on bunkers one at 20 so having a
safe way to move the tasks without
having man handling really is a good
idea and of course on the out loading
method telehandler or a lighter or
well bunker operation needs a couple of
other methods if you put on the earth
wall might be a tempest for the bunker
you can put an earth wall there the
ground sheet obviously wants to come up
and right over the top of that that wall
and then the top table will come down
and join it now I do see in the next
slide yes I have ever put any bit of
dirt around the bottom of the top here
to hold the top down
good in theory but it can cause water to
pool on top of that little that little
line there so another method is to
actually dig a trench around just
outside of the bunker or top to go down
and through and then put the soil in
into that depth of the trench so that
water running down the bunka tar will
run straight across there talking away
from the bunker site again a bit more
work the more effort but you extend it
the life of time that you can store
grain there without having an issue and
again these things operational things
are very similar to two bags we can
clean up many skills remove the grain
from the site
remove the attraction thanks aside our
faithful mice and sure it's happy still
being sort of pros and cons of bunkers
low cost to capital up front takes off
the passive flexible location obviously
requires a bit more labour
so if labor is something you can get at
our store then that's fine if labor is a
real pressure for your Tallis Tom then
then then bag can bank it may not fit
with your system
Brian quality question was aeration it
is possible in a butter he's a bit of
work and in a bit to set up so I have
don't you sit down there common but it
is possible risk of damage on Wall
Street begins rated for the ephemeral
storage and the work required for
successful fumigation not impossible but
Dow Sephora
so we have a look at the big picture of
managing grain storage overall and
thinking back to that first slide of
where the bags and bunkers fit into a
grain storage system we've really got
three three categories that I think
about in pest prevention and what do we
do this try and stop pestering in s
control what we do it with do get pests
and having many grow in quality so if we
look at those in the relationship bags
and bunkers hygiene structural
treatments and in terms of cleaning up
around the site cleaning up and loading
or unloading here if you do that if you
use our diatomaceous earth aeration
cooling I'll put a cross against that
one while you can do in Bunker's I don't
see it done very colony because it is so
much work just to set up and manage
across means that one protectants look
this is where they do have a place in
that temporary top storage and ensure
the term I'll put a question mark there
because I don't know if any one that is
actually set up a chaser bin or
something took me out or plyo
protectants at the core acquired right
it does seem to be they were challenged
to be able to get an even consistent
flow of rain calibrate that particular
station so certainly possible I just
don't see it that often so put a
question mark
yes that one but the thickness would
help of course and monitoring absolutely
you can do it I've got a question right
there because so many people I say don't
do it but I know you can even if we do
all that we do get pests or our options
to control them phosphine you say only
control with the on-farm now in bags and
bankers it is possible
research being done in both and it is
possible to fumigate it needs a bit
extra work there's quite a process to it
one of the real challenges to fumigating
in bags is actually painting getting the
phosphine back out of the bag being in
sacrifice mania and it will take a
longer really long bag there is more
information I'll show you for that just
really great quality in growing
qualities are really about moisture and
temperature management which we don't
have a lot of options in bags and
bunkers so it really relies on ask
putting the grain into both temporal
storages at the right conditions so it
is a very maintained because we don't
have much control over to sum up before
I get into the circular questions coming
in which is fantastic so keep them
coming me let's say they prepared to put
in the work and give it a good result
but it'd be unfair here talk to someone
about using bags and bankers and they
tell you that they can store it for a
long period of time successfully and
then you go home and do a do a short cap
job or noted for the quality is your set
up and then complain that you didn't
have the same result they really stick
about your expectations for storage and
bags and bunkers obviously they do have
their limitations
I do have their spot so bring out and
utilize them they doesn't work really
nice in conjunction with some permanent
storage so you can have a combination
both if you want to out load a bag get
an issue in a put out load one to have
some permanent storage out load of you
to so you might have a bag in a paddock
and then after month you've got to silo
space freed up you can transfer the
grain from the paddock
interventive storage any feedback there
if you need to but having some
flexibility
really bad well as with my things on the
farm plantain head to do your
preparation figure out your pest control
method and figure out your outgoing
method and then make sure you clean out
both the more information here the
stored grain cumberland website or you
can you can contact the nearest grain
storage specialist on 103 them shoot me
an email with some links here you can
click on the links they're successful
storage and grain bags as a fact sheet
there's a few other information
resources there for bags and bunkers if
you feel that the website and just
search bunker you come up with a few
days over there tea video which are
really quite quite handy for growers
perspective he'll the questions here i
encourage you to keep talking these
questions in and i'll try and tackle
them one of us on question here would
you feel about a bag look as i said it
is possible it is a bit more work to
fuming out in the bag you need to set up
a system you can actually put the
tablets into the bay about every 7
meters so they can liberate and then
remove the tablet after the fumigation
period obviously it relies in the bag
being sealed completely so the quality
of a bag the head with a job you've done
in actually mixing up any hole is
silastic tape because we can do a
pressure test on bags or bunkers in
ideal world would have gas monitoring
equipment that actually tell us whether
we're reaching the required two to three
hundred parts per million for a seven to
ten days then as I said the fainting is
actually one of the tricky parts of you
getting the bag so that can now
having a little fan getting some
perforated tube with a red on it or like
an order flight you can actually screw
into the staffing end of the bag open up
the bag other end of the bag where
you're finished billing and actually
suck the air to the bag so yes it's
possible
in fact this the second link I've got
here store grind up another user slash
rain bag negation foundation fill a
barrel in that video goes through the
process the I do ideal as the course of
gas starts doable storage the question
here more comment in bags if you don't
leave adequate labor upside bags in no
etching this with a a really good
comment Roy they do take a bit more
louver and you might think you can do it
on your own or they build with West
people but certainly agree with the
comments there they are given a chance
which if you try and do too much
yourself so labor something you're short
of a Paris they may not be your best bet
got plenty of people around and they're
obviously in a bit low capital cost are
there any other questions that you guys
have cooked down for few more here that
off and get a spit but please refer to
add the question there if you can
well often here is the bag he medically
sealed therefore low oxygen inside tell
you sex currently I haven't seen any
independent research to back that up so
I'm going on here say my my personal
feeling is that it's the bag was in
perfect condition it's quite possible
but reality used most bags and have some
holes in them at some point and I don't
about the option to do so the short
answer is I'm not sure that they are you
medically still I certainly wouldn't
want to rely on that of my own and
insect control then the damage and
hopefully they are sealed that they the
oxygen low inside but certainly the
question here have been problems in the
past
when used yeah good point
not Valley can can be a little more
sensitive to it to its storage certainly
in terms of moisture and temperature we
know that lower the moisture below the
temperature the better the quality of
North Valley will be maintained so again
keep your bags for the lower value
higher volumes sort of product
[Music]
Malvolio Dewey you put it into a solid
that you can have a duration to cool it
cool it rained down quickly so you think
thanks right that question or comment
are there any other questions or
comments people look up before we finish
up
well you're thinking of them perhaps
I'll just remind you next session will
be on the 12th and though then but at 10
a.m. and we're going to look at grain
protectants so approach you can spray on
to try and prevent insects and snow or
grains also please keep an eye in your
email inbox for a quick 30 second name
survey just a feedback for us as I said
if you'd like more information stored
grain calm today new web site is a whole
kind of information there you can email
me info it's stored grain combo you will
call 100 weapon in touch with you in the
nearest grain storage specialist there's
an app gac store brain app also has some
information and monitoring capability
there so feel free to make use of it
yeah that offer I'll make if you would
like more information on grain storage
and you've got a few people in your
region on-farm training session or
workshop at your place so feel free to
contact us if that's something that you
think would be helpful if there aren't
any more questions I might bring the
webinar to a close and thank you very
much for your participation and then
your questions I appreciate that
and hopefully see you again on November
at crying particulars